[Music]
all right every hey me cool so before I
begin I just like to ask a really quick
question could you put your hands up if
you've ever been so scared in your life
so frightened that a little bit of pee
has come out keep your hands up
okay that's about 50% of the audience
and there hopefully by the end of this
talk I will have increased that number a
little bit because today we're talking
about web security and hacking my name
is asked to me same on Twitter you can
find me at jaw 8 I blog about JavaScript
and angular on my site code Croft TV and
I'm something called a cloud developer
advocate and Microsoft so I work on the
is your team or with the is your team
and yeah I talk about cloud and security
net and I and JavaScript in a bunch of
those things but to begin with today I
want to talk to you one tell you a story
the story of my first startup
it's called event sushi it was an event
site that aggregated events from a bunch
of different places from Meetup Facebook
last.fm a few of the places
at the time I used to work in investment
banking my career was going very well
there was good money but this just this
was just a side project but you know it
was going slightly ok very very slightly
so I did where everybody does in this
situation on that I quit a really good
job well paying to work on something
quite risky and I told you I was in
investment banking so of course I was
very very arrogant
I had it at the start had investors who
are interested investing in me but I was
like no no no no this is gonna be a
billion dollar startup I don't want your
money I want a hundred percent so I said
no so you can probably guess where I'm
going with this six months later the
product hadn't you know didn't wasn't a
billion dollar startup I was running out
money this is my money
not invest as money my money I didn't
have enough money to pay rent in two
months so I didn't start going
after the same investors saying hey look
I'm interested now but they could tell
they could tell that I was now desperate
they were backing away they didn't want
to invest a pot from one guy we've been
talking for six months he lied me you
liked the product and he said asked him
okay look
give me another demo in seven days show
me what you built recently and then
we'll talk and it was a good chance
who's gonna invest yes but then 48 hours
before the meeting with the investor I
got emailed by Leonard Cellino were the
people I was using to host my website
and they said look assam it looks like
your servers being compromised we can
see it's making hundreds of requests to
other servers and if you don't solve the
problem in four in 24 hours we're gonna
shut you down
so in 48 hours I was gonna have a
life-saving meeting with an investor and
in 24 hours I was gonna get shut down by
Linode so I panicked
you know jumped onto the server I
started looking around and to cut a long
story short I definitely got hacked
definitely got hacked
I found stuff in a temp folder there
were scripts that were running that was
doing brute-force attacks on a bunch of
IP addresses I'm not talking like what
what is going on how did I get hacked
and then after a bit more investigation
I saw the PHP was running why is PHP
running I'm not a PHP developer right
then I remembered when I first set up
the server I'd installed WordPress okay
I got rid of it straight away but I
forgot to remove it from the start
script so when the server rebooted PHP
started and that's how the hackers got
in so you know I cleaned everything up
removed from the start script contacted
they know they were happy
had the meeting with the investor he
invested the startup still failed but
had some money so I'm no fool I'm not an
idiot
I took security very very seriously when
I set up that server I'd followed all of
the instructions
I just forgot on one tiny tiny tiny
small thing so I think the lesson is
that if it can happen to me it can
happen to you so you might guess that I
love stories so today I'm gonna talk to
you about hacking but through a series
of four different hacking stories some
of these stories are going to be
specific to notes um some are gonna be
more general web development each
story's gonna have a moral at the end a
lesson to learn and perhaps some steps
you can use to protect yourself and I
think to begin with let's just start off
by breaking down exactly how I think I
got hacked on event sushi but first let
me just explain a few terms so a
vulnerability is a hole in your security
a weakness so for instance not setting
up a firewall is a hole in your
Security's of vulnerability an exploit
is a tool or a piece of code or even
just a sequence of your commands that
you execute which takes advantage of a
vulnerability to do bad things okay so
who here has heard the term zero-day
exploit yeah so a zero-day exploit is
one that nobody knows about yet okay
crew
but once a zero-day exploit is found out
about is known about perhaps a white hat
hacker has discovered it and informed
the company it's not called a zero-day
exploit anymore
anybody call their a1 there or 3:30 or a
six-month expletive yeah will you call
it that but just to think about just the
way to think about it basically once a
zero-day exploit becomes known the clock
starts ticking let me ask you a question
how hard do you think you would be to
get a hold of a zero-day exploit pretty
hard right now you need to be the right
kind of person you need to know the
right kinds of people there's a study
done caramba when maybe last year they
estimated that a zero-day exploit is
sold for about quarter million dollars
each the usually salt to criminal
organizations or state-run hacking
organizations but how hard do you think
it would be to get a hold of a six month
old exploit not very hard
in fact it's it's just it's actually
really really easy you can just find on
the Internet
this is one website exploit DB listless
bunch of sizes this is just one of them
and it's pretty easy to use siphon PHP
it's got a capture hit search and take a
look at this these are all the exploits
is found look at the date we're still in
2017 PHP isn't very secure okay I can
tell it got some PHP developers in the
audience
so we want you know this
yeah mr. robot so we all like to believe
all of the Oliver hackers are like this
blackhat mysterious geniuses and I think
we like to believe that because it makes
us feel better when we do get hacked I
mean if we got hacked and you can just
say well how am I supposed to protect
myself and mr. robot come on
but mr. robot didn't hack me didn't use
a zero they exploit to get into my
server I was running a really old
version of PHP my attacker googled how
to hack me and followed instructions
it's not hard in fact it's even easier
than that I mean we're all developers in
this room how many of us has been a day
writing a script to automate something
that takes us two minutes we all do all
the time so why would hackers do the
same and they do all the time this is a
automated tool called Metasploit which
you can basically point to a website and
it will scan it for known runner built
vulnerabilities and it also has a bunch
of plugins in here and you can store
other plugins that you want that will
also perform automated attacks as well
there's another study that estimated
about 27% of all websites in the world
can be hacked automatically
so what can we do what can we do to to
protect ourselves from this let's not
not much you can do about zero day
exploits okay you still you can't
protect yourself from something you
don't know about but you can defend
yourself from the unknown all you've got
to do is make sure you keep all of your
stuff we're updated all the time you
know make sure you keep the webserver
updated oh the operating system itself
make sure you keep that updated
oh I'm using nginx gotta make sure I'm
keeping tap dated and on my database
gotta make sure I'm gonna keep my
database updated all the time and oh my
god I'm using em PMS need to make sure
man p.m. modules of data real-time also
need to listen to security bulletins as
well and make sure I patch my software
as soon as soon as anything gets updated
especially not that easy and your job
isn't to do all of that stuff your job
is to write functionalities to write
software for your end-users and that's
why after I got hacked this one time
I've started to exclusively use houses
just explain what house is back in the
old old days or even now if you sold it
now and if you want to deploy something
yet to have some sub on-premise Hardware
you'd buy a server you maybe you hope
you put it in your own room or you go to
server farm and they will just put it in
there for you but you're in charge of
the hardware if the hard drive fails is
up to you to fix it but then you're also
responsible for the operating system
keeping that updated and the web server
run the database and everything else and
your application as well you've got
obviously keep updated then we have
infrastructure as a service so that
stuff like what Linode Amazon Web
Services is your Google we've all got
stuff like this and that's basically
when you get a VM so somebody else is
responsible for looking after your
hardware if the hard drive fails they
fix it
but you still have to handle the
operating system the web server with a
database everything else and of course
your application as well and then we
have passes platform as a service so
they handle the hardware they also
handle the operating system depending on
the powers of another web server and a
database and everything else as well and
you just focus on deploying your
application and the thing with passes is
they've got teams of people teams or
security experts and all their job is
every single day is making sure there's
no security holes patching every
vulnerability as soon as it gets
released okay I know there's a bunch of
them out there
I work in Microsoft so we've got one
called as your app services Google's got
Google App Engine
Amazon Beanstalk and there's another one
I've used Polaroid but there's a bunch
of others as well so and if you're still
kind of a little bit and there's a lot
of people who are kind of used to using
VMs and installing all around software
and managing all this stuff themselves
that a little bit suspicious of what I'm
saying who's heard of the Equifax hack
happened earlier on this year ok it's
the largest ever hack in history but 200
million people's records were taken
Equifax the billion dollar company about
ten thousand employees did the hack is
gained through a zero-day exploit no
they got in through a known exploit of
Apache struts which is a Java web
framework
patch to the fix was available for two
months before the hackers got in all the
Equifax had to do to defend from this
attack was apply an update that just
never updated their software largest
hack in history Oh in the firm that cook
one of the coolest things about is your
that I like is something called he is
your security center so as far as I can
tell and correct me from wrong no one
else has got this yet so one of the
problems with detecting attacks is as
low as a different signals all over the
place and if you just alerted I'm every
single signal then that just be too much
noise and you start ignoring the ellipse
so to solve this we trained in AI so we
took a whole load of attack data we said
this hall at a date so we said these
signals are from definite attacks we
trained up an AI so now we've beaten all
of your signals through this ai and we
alert you only when well the AI alerts
now it's not perfect but it's easy just
switch a button it switched on and I'm
lazy so I just have to switch it on
does anybody know this show nobody don't
worry about it I think I'm one of the
three fans of this show in the world
it's called this so it's always sunny in
philadelphia very funny I recommend a
finger on the eleventh season now and
this is one of the characters called
Charlie Kelly and he plays the dumbest
guy in the show he like cleans the
toilets and kills rats that make sense
as you watch it but one of the things is
he thinks he thinks he's a lawyer
so never he gets into trouble he always
represents himself in court very badly
represents him himself in court so my
closing arguments of this
thinking you can create a secure
platform to host your application when
you're not a security expert is like
thinking you can represent yourself in
court when you're not a lawyer so did I
scare anybody just yet
no you're all pretty pretty calm I can
tell there's no I can't we see the fear
in the you I can't smell it maybe the
next one so I'm in the UK I'm based in
the UK in the UK when you register a
company you have to register with the
government was something called
Companies House so if you actually went
to Companies House website and search
for my company Dell Reaver Limited you
would find me here and this is an actual
company in the UK space this is the
address yeah and what this is this is an
example of an attack something called an
injection attack something specifically
called a sequel injection attack and the
point of kind of any injection attack is
to run untrusted code in a trusted
environment so basically to trick you in
running this sequel code here so how
does that work maybe you've got a script
which gets all the names and you want to
grab some details from your database but
if you actually put the name of the
company in here you'd end up with
something like this select star for a
company where name is you mmm nothing
drop table companies and then a comment
man
you might be saying so what a Seng I've
backed up my company's table I'm not
really bothered about this I'll just
restore it but then the drop table isn't
the only command you can run on a
database and just like a lot of things
there's automated tools which help to
attack so look at this on sequel map
automated SQL injection and database
take over to take over
so what does this do well you would run
it
there we go it's a Python script pass it
some endpoint there's an API endpoint
which has a injection attack
vulnerability if they're scans it
figures our is my sequel the version
number different aspects about the
database and then okay
now we know it's my sequel let's try it
with a common set of passwords for my
sequels it's brute-force attacking and
there we go found the password for it
now let's have a list of the databases
let's list all the tables that's now
what's it gonna do now oh yeah let's
dump a table let's dump the users table
yeah okay no biggie but my sequel also
lets you do things like OS shell which
they should run commands on the server
my sequels running on so we're running
LS and now we're catching the password
file all from one vulnerability in your
script so in about a minute that's a
minute
in about a minute we ran that script and
got the egg set to pass a file from your
server awesome morale this story acting
the moral of this story is never assume
that your inputs will arrive in the
format that you expect okay and the kind
of solution for this and this kind
generous across a lot of problems a lot
of whole vulnerabilities in this base is
to do something called sanitization okay
you're you've got untrusted input that
name was untrusted someone else is
providing that so you have to sanitize
it it's a bunch of different methods of
sanitizer you want notice equal you can
use sequel string where you pass it some
untrusted sequel it will escape stuff
that it knows is dangerous and that you
run the output command output sequel
and if you're using as your sequel
database we also have detection
capabilities or you can detect injecting
sequel statements that we know are
suspecting are basically injection
attacks and we alert you on there we
don't stop the sequel from being execute
we just alert you on it and then feed
him it's their AI as well so you can
change you can actually see in a chain
how we think you got sequel injection
attacks oh we think that somebody logged
into your server and you can follow this
path through your system so that was a
second story I'm feeling now a little
bit more why I did I did just show
everybody how to completely take over a
server in a minute using okay you get a
tough crowd well I don't know maybe the
next story anybody heard of this this
company no I still use them perforce so
this is github we all know github
hopefully and github has something
called a bug bounty where basically they
all like pay you if you find a security
hole in their software and you tell them
about it first you tell them about it
privately and you give them a chance to
fix it before you tell everybody in the
world so there's a really great exploit
found by this user called orange sigh
this is their Twitter follow them I
think posting some of the interesting
stuff and it was with github Enterprise
and they basically found a way to run
any command on a github server the
server itself okay and they did this by
chaining a number of smaller exploits
together into one really big exploit
and and I really liked it because it
reminded me of like a heist movie know
movies where they rob a bank this story
really reminds me of something like that
so I'd love to share it with you so we
know webhooks
or with maybe we know web hooks and
github where you can set up github so
when you do a git push it does a post to
some end point that you define pretty
straightforward right
but what if you set up the web Booker's
blog post mm-hmm what what happened then
well then when you do a git push behind
the firewall it would then do a post to
something internal to the server
remember you can have localhost with a
port number so you can post to any
process running on that same machine but
you know this is github very known
Beneful x' they were using a sanitizer
because that is untrusted input and that
sanitizer knew the local host was a
potential problems always strip it out
but forgot about zero okay on some
server zero would also point to
localhost so then okay
found a way in so now we've got one
small vulnerability where you can do a
git push and post to some process on
your server but what what can you
actually do with that well the server
was also running elasticsearch we know
elasticsearch that runs on port 9200 and
if you do a post trip hate HTTP POST
request to this port and this endpoint
it shuts down elasticsearch
but you know it's not a biggie it's not
a big no biggest issue in the world then
started looking for another
vulnerability to chain onto this start
looking at the code and found this okay
so I know this is - don't worry about it
I'll take you through so the server is
also running another process called
graphite was the Python process that
lets you do kind charting and things
like that
and it's open source so it's checked
into github so on github
you found the source code for it and
then this was one of the functions as it
gets called on a on an API request and
just to take you through what this is
doing it gets there the URL from the
query parameters gets the path and then
does it get request to that path does it
get request that path so what we're
talking about here well now if you set
your your web hook to this URL 800 is
graphite when you do a git push it will
post to this endpoint that endpoint is
that send email function it will take
this URL and then do a get request
so all that these done is have turned a
post into a get a post into again on its
own maybe not such a big deal but
but the actual method their actual
library they use them to make that
request it's called HTTP connection it's
a Python library that has a known
vulnerability something called carriage
return line feed so Kara turn the
backslash R is how you did new lines and
windows and backslash n is new line
everywhere else so but you know if you
convert that to hex it would look like
this
oh do a so now what happens when you
make a get request to this okay so when
converted into the protocol they might
look like this but hey CP connection
library will convert these two new lines
and then we're sending this okay so what
is HTTP what is it what is hasty P HTTP
is you open up a TCP connection to this
host and port and then you're sending it
a bunch of strings and if that host and
port recognizes those strings it goes oh
this is HTTP connection with a snippy
message I know what to do but if it gets
something this doesn't look like HTTP
it's just going on this is a malformed
the message it's going to kick it out of
the way right that's what's happening
here okay so what you can send a
malformed haste VP message to the server
but what if you did this
okay that port is memcache now if you
try to do a get request to this you
actually end up sending a HTTP method
message like this again we're opening up
a TCP port to memcache memcache doesn't
know what this means
oh it's back memcache doesn't know what
the first line means this is gonna
ignore it right the second line is a
memcache understands this it knows what
this is this is setting the key the
value data into the key key so it will
do something with that it will then
ignore this line at this then this thing
doesn't know what these are okay
what have we done we've done something
called protocol smuggling okay in a HTTP
message we've managed to smuggle the
memcache protocol and so now we can set
data in memcache oh I forgot
okay so as developers we all like to
store stuff in memcache and restore some
Co serialize it store in memcache
deserialize it execute it we're happy
but we're all pretty lazy people so we
probably don't do that serialization
manually you probably use a library
where you pass an object serializes it
for us thaws in memcache take it back
the lab your uncie realizes it I'm the
executor sometime but now we can set
some data in memcache so as a developer
you're going to serialize your objects
you're going to store it in memcache
later on you're gonna deserialize your
objects but you're not deserializing
your object but deserializing my object
you're gonna execute a function not get
to execute your function you can execute
my function okay
I'm looking through the keys in the
memcache found this
so when you say realize a bunch of
objects you might depending the library
might store the name of the class which
is getting serialize so they were using
deprecated instance variable proxy
instance variable proxy had a known
vulnerability so they put deprecated in
front of it but they still used it so
then it basically had a vulnerability
where if you deserialize an instance of
instance variable proxy you can execute
a command so then this is what the
eventual webpop looks like you've got
the first one it's that simple posts
gets converted into a the second one to
get then this is the memcache key so you
can do set that's the key this is the
deserialize data and icon where it is
somewhere in here this is it this is the
command when we deserialize this object
the ID command gets run on the server so
this is what they used to prove their
case and get get the money examples are
working you go to your profile click on
a repository settings add a web for
runs a script to get the eventual name
okay gets their webhook URL puts it in
[Music]
gets ready to listen to any command to
get run on the server and then to run
that thing just basically does a search
any search that's going to request that
data from memcache the D serialization
then runs the ID command on the server
hmm the moral of the story
big exploits are made from smaller
exploits okay we like to think are our
attacks coming through one big giant
security hole but they don't you chain
multiple smaller exploits together so
you know if you find a vulnerability in
your software anything yeah it's not
that big a deal now fix it cuz the
github is vulnerability the only thing
they had in their code pretty small how
you feeling now a little bit more okay
I've got a rush to the next one but
we'll go through fast all right what
does this code do it takes your
environment variables see that there's
guess the string of um random variables
okay what does this code do what's why
is my surprise my server there Oh
if you ran this code it looks like it
would take all of your environment
variables and post them to my server
what if I told you I could make you run
this code on your server who here puts
like private things in there and random
variables
I don't yeah okay maybe maybe this makes
it clearer what this is
I should get an extra minute for this
maybe this makes it clearer it's some
sort of setup script in fact maybe this
makes it clearer it's actually a an NPM
module and this is a setup script for an
NPM module if you install this NPM
module you would send me all of your
environment variables okay
he probably saying Assam iodine store
your npm module he saw this is Kirk
almost two months ago now so Kent Dodds
had a npm module called cross ends and
they found that somebody else had create
their own cross named module the real
one was crossed hi for them the fate one
was cross
and without the - this is downloaded a
million times a day by the way so if you
installed cross them without the hyphen
you are sending your environment
variables to somebody - hacker how many
times have you sat then and can't quite
remember the npm module names you try it
without the hyphen any like yeah would
great that's what happens so the moral
the stories were a little bit too
trusting okay and I think maybe it's
because it was open source we kind of
trust open source data we don't really
question it now MPM have taken down
cross them they've they've got rid of
all the ones they could find associated
with that account but you can't really
protect yourself from that okay well you
can do with NPM now as you can
absolutely call scope packages basically
you can own the scope and then only you
can publish things under it that's a
solution to you stopping yourself
getting typos spotted on which is what
that's called
but it doesn't stop you from
accidentally installing something like
cross them yeah just needs to keep your
your mind clear on that one
just in summary okay what the takeaways
stop pretending
stop retain that because you spend a few
minutes thinking about security that you
can create your own platform to run
software and use the pass don't assume
the inputs will come in the format that
you expect sanitize don't think that
just there's just a small one durability
acting Nora fix it don't trust anyone
and I don't have a solution for that so
there's a unicorn and and that's it if
you do want to know a little bit more my
colleague has a course on no jet
security I'll post up these slides on
Twitter in a second so you want to
follow me follow me at joy and then now
post up all the slides and I'll have
links for everything and I've just
mentioned in this course in this course
in this talk including all the links to
all the vulnerabilities and things I
mentioned and that's it very much
[Music]